good morning believe nation my name is
Alex and my one word is belong and I
believe that the world would be a better
place if more people felt that they
belong so to help you on your journey
today's messages don't stop over to you
Tony Robbins there is another level the
only reason you keep seeing there isn't
as you feel so exhausted about where you
are but life the universe or God is just
testing you because there is another
level if this is good
giant jump to excellence Giants start a
good pour to good to excellence there's
a level where all your dreams are
realized there's a level that you've
always dreamed that it is real it has
not gone away but it takes that extra
burst when you think there's nothing
left there's no way you've tried
everything ten million times and you
keep going it's almost like God is
saying if you keep hitting this wall
enough times I will see that you will
not stop that you were filled with that
level of determination faith and courage
and then the door opens and you get to
that next level but most people don't
know is the next level is just two
millimeters above and it's called
outstanding ladies and gentlemen
outstanding what's it called what's it
called what's it called outstanding
magnificent unstoppable extraordinary
not excellent it's a different level
it's a level where you are not one of
the best you are the best you know
what's amazing you only have to be two
millions more than everybody else and
you get everything you get the joy the
last day the fun in the family the
passion the economics the freedom the
spirit it's all there what Jerry Maguire
called
the Quan baby all of it and it's just
two million years above and most
excellent people give up because they're
exhausted and there some people go the
harder I hit it the more I hit it sooner
or later it's going down I'm not
stopping and when you do that enough it
pops open
this message resonates for me a lot on
two levels actually want to share a
quick story with you Navy SEALs have
some of the hardest training that they
have to go through both mental and
physical to graduate and one of the most
difficult things that they have to go
through is called hell week in this one
week they sleep probably anywhere from 4
to 10 hours in 7 days spent both their
mind their body and their spirit gets
pushed to the limits now here's the
thing they've been training for this
hell week surviving things like drown
proofing where their arms and legs get
tied they get tossed in a pool and they
essentially have to get used to being
drowned these are top specimens that you
can think of both physically and
mentally men and women and then this
last week they just need to graduate and
survive one more week and so here's the
thing that's mind blowing every morning
whether it's 3 a.m. or 4 a.m. when their
instructor wakes them up they line up on
the beach and next to them there's a
brass bell if they want to quit all they
have to do is ring the bell they ring
the bell
they quit that's it it's done they pack
up the stuff and leave and you want to
know what's the mind-blowing thing most
people quit not when they get their
hands tied and throw in the pool when
you have to jump into ice-cold water
when they have to hold a log over their
head for 4 or 5 hours most people quit
in the morning most people quit at the
idea of doing those tasks only a handful
people actually quit while they're
struggling through it while they're
trying to hold their breath and get used
to being drowned so what does it tell
you about the human capacity a lot of
the people that ring the bell are
quitting because of the idea of what's
coming well most people that actually
when they get into it they make it
through and isn't that the truth often
the thing that sykes us out the thing
that we hold ourselves back on is their
idea of going back to the gym is that
idea of doing that last set of you're
working out is the idea that you want to
read that extra book to get better at
something that you're trying to learn
about leadership or whatever so here's
the thing that you can learn from Navy
SEALs while being in the mole
and something difficult is coming your
way and you don't want to stop remember
that it's a state of mind that often
people quit and not when they're in the
situation so anytime you start doubting
yourself anytime you want to stop
anytime you want to quit on something
that's important to you realize that my
fear the reason I want to stop the
reason I want to quit is simply because
I'm imagining how difficult is gonna be
but once you put yourself in that
situation just like those Navy SEALs
you'll make it through and the second
thing that's really important to raise
your standards it's important just like
Tony talks about it for greatness to
happen don't be okay when things are
just fine or okay or they're alright
push through the wall because ultimately
that's where greatness waits for you the
question of the day is where in your
life right now you're seeing some
success that you don't want to stop in
and what can you do about it right now
leave it at comments below I'm really
excited to see what you have to say I
also want to give a big shout-out to
Scott J Weaver senior Scott thank you so
much for purchasing your one word it
really means a lot to us and I hope
you're enjoying the book thank you so
much for watching we believe in you and
we hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
and we'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of espresso
[Music]
I've learned if your father
Farmar understands better than any other
worker in this country a farmer has an
understanding that most people never
achieve in their life I really respect
the farmers and their commitment but I
respect also their understanding my
grandfather my uncle the thing was to
wake up early in the morning before you
start your day you start the day by
feeding all the animals I never
understood that why am i feeding
slopping these hogs baling this hay for
these cows take your food out to the
hunting dogs I'm going to get these
mills and horses walking them down to
water why am i feeding these chickens
man all this before I my grandfather 70
Gandhi said young man if we don't take
care of these animals that we are
requiring to take care of us he said
what's gonna happen to us he said we
dependent on them chickens to lay eggs
to give us meat we depended on them hogs
for me we depended on the news to pull
the plow so we complained we depended on
them horses to drag all these wagons
were we dependent on these hunting dogs
to go out in wood and I'm cover two
animals for he said in what I respect
about farmers is they understand that
everything comes in seasons there is a
planting season and you got to plant and
play and play and play
flower teal hold a rose you got to do
all that
seeded fertilizer in order for co-op to
grow
now here's what happened some years some
years it's a drought there ain't no way
ain't no crops sometimes it's a flood
wipe out all on the crops all the plants
but guess what you still got to do the
plant because what you're banking on is
just enough rain just enough sunshine so
you can harvest and even if they crops
get washed out even if the floods come
even if the droughts call you know thing
about a farmer they do it all over again
because they understand that eventually
you'll be able to harvest and that's
what I respect about farmers and that's
my life I wanted to talk to you about
like there's a transition that very
successful people make and either they
make it or they don't and the the
transition is to go from being hungry
and filled with all this angst being
like stupid wealthy and famous but still
keeping your art relevant mm-hmm like
how do you do that uh we're super
competitive people were really
perfectionist and we hate to let each
other down there's a there's always a
better riff coming there's always a
better album maybe there's the never
satisfied part to us that will keep us
going till we die you know there's
always the ultimate lyric that's going
to connect to everyone in the world or
something there is always a better
something that we haven't got yet life
demands that you pick up the pace if you
don't pick up the pace
Maes that the people that lack the
flexibility to pick up the pace they
just get in a read I scroll down here
and I'm gonna scroll back and go stroll
over here I'm gonna stroll over there
one of the most amazing thing about the
disaster at Malaysia is that when it
happened
everybody had to pick up the pace all
the news media had to pick up the pace
they were booking night flights and
flying over here and flying over there
somebody had to work overtime won't be
home for three days typing in the middle
of night research going or because when
something happens everybody gotta pick
up the pace that's why I can't deal with
people who cannot pick up the pace
don't be strolling when I got a man one
one on you and the people who can pick
up the pace
sloppy David said pick up the pace
something is about to happen pick up the
pace something's about to happen pick up
the pace something is about to happen
pick up the pace something is about to
happen pick up the pace something is
about to happen
pick up the pace something's about to
have it I came to tell the young people
[Applause]
the danger of low expectations
I would rather aim for the stars and not
hit them then to not aim at all I would
rather go after it and not get it did
not go after it at all I'd rather try
and sail did not try at all I don't want
to live with the idea wonder what would
have happened had I done more with my
life I'm gonna go for it come hell or
high water I'm going after my destiny
since the neighbors say run you gotta
run out to your destiny you can't stroll
after your destiny
you can't walk after your destiny you
gotta run somebody Holloway
you gotta run you gotta run you gotta
run
you can't just wake up in the morning
let me see what's gonna happen today
I don't know what I'm gonna do I don't
know what I'm aware don't know what I'm
okay I don't know where I'm gonna go
I just woke up oh you should stay in the
bed give the day to somebody who's gone
wrong after their destiny give the day
to somebody who has a plan who has a
strategy because success is never an
accident and if you don't want it get
out of my way because there are some
people who want to do something with
their life
[Applause]